[Music]
pedaling ten thousand five hundred
kilometers crossing Africa and the Middle
East passing through 15 countries
[Music] [
Music]
traveling by bicycle is very beautiful it's
something incredible because we go we
skip nowhere we go doing
the tour feeling the ambush little
tree each house each face to each
family everything that is happening
kilometers km so we are
soaking up all the reality of the
places
[Music] [
Music]
and solidarity that for each kilometer That we
remember to change it for a little tree
for the land, accordingly, then it
will be 10,000 kilometers of 10,500
little trees for the sum of kilometers,
so that's not what we are going to carry
[Music]